the Amazon River for me it represents
a living organism
that connects the person connects cultures
knowledge
all the essence of the forest is in the rivers
is in the dynamics of the rivers all the exchange that
occurs in the Amazon from the
gaseous exchanges to the cultural exchanges the exchange
of knowledge is  moved by the rivers
so I believe that the whole of society
should look very fondly at the
future of rivers because they are key
to maintaining the forest in the future
for a long time they tried to find
solutions for the conservation of the Amazon
in external places when in fact the
local communities come  interacting with the
forest with biodiversity for
hundreds or thousands of years
in our project The idea is to try to
understand how local communities
can coexist with the
Amazonian megafauna that are the big animals there
I'm talking about the black caiman of the Ariranha
do Boto do pirarucu  da Tartaruga
are very important
emblematic species that are important both
for local cultures and for the
local economy and that have been
overexploited in recent decades have not
had their populations reduced and
now through some
Community-based arrangements these species are
resurfacing and we want to understand
What are the mechanisms by which
local communities can recover
populations of these large species
[Music]